I can read you quicker than you would
want me to I cannot blame Scarface or a
computer game or a rapper for my
behavior you do actually get natural
leaders and natural soldiers and luckily
I am a leader yeah if you ever get a
rescued while on cocaine the hardest
thing in the world to do is go no coming
no I'm not saying nothing okay a little
bit of it I have a very very scary phone
book mate yeah it's not what I can do
anymore is it so if you are Camilla
so all of a sudden I had a 900 strong
army the Moore family should get for
being naughty the less know you can be
now my biggest threat to them is I'm
making crime look glamorous do you think
you are though no I'm not I'm not
leveraging crime I'm glamorizing Dave
[Music]
so today we have a special guest with us
he is he is a different form of a bill
collector he is a collector some of you
may be bill collectors his form of
collecting was in a different way in UK
he is known as the monarch of the
underworld the yellow pages of the
underworld in UK that's none other than
David Courtney how are you sir yes it's
good to meet you good you have a very
interesting resume so you and I'm afraid
off of its truth yes see that's what
makes it interesting fact that happen if
10% of it is true it's interesting let
alone half of it so when I read up on
you you know you see the word celebrity
gangster you were a you work security
with the Kray twins Kray twins the movie
in America you know with Tom Hardy a
thing was called legend as what it was
called and it sure does some of the
movies about him real neat movie you've
associated with some interesting people
in your life how did you become a
gangster like how did you get into this
world yourself I don't really think you
can blame your environment of how you
turn no you can't say there was no green
areas for me to play on and the
classrooms were to paint so I ended up
robbing a post office you can set it
you're born Louie you're born you're
saying born oh yeah I do say that oh you
believe that true you don't think it's a
solution that are god-fearing cubben
Scout leaders so there's no reason
that's all I need uprightness I was born
with the genes they're just in me I
cannot blame Scarface or a computer game
or a rapper for my behavior
yeah it might influence me if I'm skint
I can't blame you on that because you're
a bull noe and the people that are not
born or he that try to be no he they're
the one who ended up being snitches and
cowards and doing the wrong thing on the
day and making me deal with the police
and that word celebrity gangster there's
a media word
yeah the two words don't go in every
gangster yeah it's like saying police
intelligence yeah the two words just
don't go yeah yeah so but but I read
something about a nine years old yet
something that inspired
you know something happened that in
Spidey at around nine years old and what
was it what took plate was there any
specific even I can't actually get one
event I'm afraid AK ever cocky this
might sound you do actually get natural
leaders and natural soldiers yeah I
agree with that
you gotta know what you are as quick as
possible and so not to be put into the
wrong category because each one is
exactly the same importance as the other
one and luckily I am a leader at very
early age I realized that the art of
delegation is as important as the days
of the best fighter was the one in
charge and affirm that is very end of
fold as a bit counter you know coming a
barbarian and they're always the best
fighter on the firm in always the most
intelligent maybe is a little bit not
the sharpest pencil in amongst yeah but
you know and horses for courses and I
was very good at delegating who what
where and what age at what into dude the
jus your bone with that you can't learn
that but did you are you the older
brother or you Don the elder brother yet
so I'm not massive family one brother
one sister one brother one sister a lot
of cousins did you have but there but I
was a definitely the black sheep of the
family
my biggest weapon that I have I can read
you quicker than you would want me to
sorry how could read you quicker than
you would want me to and humor is of
maximum and published to me yeah
laughing keeping it funny keeping it on
a good bounce in every single thing I do
whoever you're sitting outside a house
went to show someone you can either be
sitting there [ __ ] yourself or just
trying to keep it good humoured yeah I
never know what problem is gonna knock
on my door 24 hours a day and as long as
I'm taking over in a good happy bouncy
mood all day long I handle all them
problems better I'm gonna good mood then
I am if I'm walking around with yeah I
don't do that
yeah most of the people are no do but I
don't do that you don't Estes it's not
my feet really yeah no no I don't do
that I'm not saying I haven't had a puff
I don't have a good drink now man yep
I've watched it turns heroes of mine
into [ __ ]
I don't do that
and I don't ever want to be in the
position where because of what I tell
people to do gets done that I ever have
to make a decision one I'm wired yeah
and I went we're just point out in him
and I didn't really mean that just
because I was flying god I don't do that
what you see is what you get yeah that
is very unenviable way to live your
February 17 59 is oh yeah say it so I
watch to see connect the dots to see
where does your wiring come from so
obviously style your parents because
your parents are you said god-fearing
yeah you know good people doing what
they're doing and you learn at an early
age so you had the delegation part so
when would you say was the first time
you committed your first crime we were
like you know what I enjoy doing it was
there something that you boys and I
never look to X crime okay I was
enjoying myself I was being center of
attraction
I didn't look here's always been extra
brave or I was the courageous one yeah I
didn't realize I was gifted having a
fight until quite late on in my life
I'll never at sea I hang around before
the big kids or the naughty kids for in
full anal 15 my friends were 28 so I
never had to have a fight they were all
doing it for me how old was your first
fight what hold we win oh god now you
have your fights at school and all that
but that's not worth talking about by
the first real real fight look Oh first
real better I had wisdom with a builder
Monday in a pub who had to bail on with
the hammer and the screwdrivers and you
just know the scariest thing in the
world you know I mean and it was the
first real man-to-man back to a walk and
remember a pin you have now you're
famous were saying you you can outfight
and outdance almost any man you've said
that yes pochi I'll use a knuckle duster
uh-huh yeah that's my choice windows I
truly believe in this if you are someone
has to carry a weapon for your day job a
prison officer a dorm and a debt
collector a soldier where you must
choose the weapon that you are prepared
to do the prison sentence for all right
what I mean by that is if you choose to
carry a gun or a knife mm-hmm forget the
time you're gonna pull the knife and
save your life
what will most probably happen is you'll
be driving down a road hit someone up
the ass in his new car he would jump out
of his car drag you out stop banging you
a new wood
if you had it in your pocket go and get
20 years which you dented his bumper
yeah if he was walking around Tesco's
and you trod on his foot and he just had
a corn operation and he tell me to stop
beating you up and you had it in your
pocket you would go and get 20 years
because you also don't carry the weapon
you don't want to do the prison sentence
for a knuckle duster you will go bang
knock him out and that's it you ain't
gonna die is Geor go over there you
might get 18 months and I don't mind
getting AE months every time I have a
fire but I'm not gonna risk getting life
imprisonment every time I have to fight
somebody you'd they're calculating
wherever when a kohli choose the weapon
you don't mind doing the bird for ya
and I don't mind getting ie much you
know I see if I get cold but because
I'll wrap mine up in plaster and no one
ever saw it already on they just thought
I was the best puncher in the world you
know
knocking about all over the place here
and and I'll run a big team of Dorman's
in London just before the rave seen it
so I had about 800 flat nosed
bald-headed thugs working for me so in
and I was like a job centre in the week
so on a Friday Saturday and Sunday night
they were doorman but all week they just
say oh I'm in the gym so if anyone won't
need somebody beat up their car
repossessed some squatters thrown out
whatever yeah you wouldn't you might not
know to ask but you know the doorman of
the nightclub you know the eight guys
all standing here they will either do it
or they will know where to point to get
it done so all of a sudden I had a nine
hundred strong army reporting to you
this is important to me yeah and then
the rave scene came in you know that's
not saying I mean what you're is that
what you're is a rave scene in late 80s
yeah yeah without you sure yeah yeah
well you learn in hundred nine hundred
and fifty paranoia's of wages as a
doorman yeah
now they were selling these easy in the
nightclub at twenty pounds each
and it was the doorman that controlled
there yeah the doorman controlled you
can come in and sell them all right I'll
get X amount of parents for letting you
do that and I will do my job and throw
everyone else out there selling them so
I look like I'm doing my job the police
rapid with me I'm frying them out
every my bum leaving you in there you
give me a thousand pound an iron to sell
them and that way you've got no other
competition in there so and then all of
a sudden you're owning four or five
grand a night so now you're it's worth
getting involved in a drug war for when
it's people turning up going I want to
be the doorman aim of guns we want to
run this club it's worth fighting for
because you're now going on with a
thousand pound are not wages yes so
you're involved in drug wars then it all
goes is a slow slow process but it
turned into that way and then my dog my
army of debt collectors car repossession
French Quarter turned into an army in
new authorities eyes of drug dealing
English gangsters which I suppose we
molded into but didn't set out to be
John I mean yeah no one said to me I
want to go and be a G yeah nobody does
want to be a G but sometimes like you
said something earlier so I mean that's
that's late 80s Early 90s let's go back
a little bit so let me ask you say I'm
in high school with you okay we were 16
17 years old who were you in high school
I was the funniest guy knows loves to
cook gesture and I have handled the cook
gesture thing in the big gangster
situations I've been in in
life-threatening situations I've been in
when I've been in the Old Bailey at the
Old Bailey
I went dressed as a cook jester with the
bells and the policemen and in the cool
open if went up in in prison afraid to
cook Chester in prison it's kept me out
of trouble I have an extra hanging on
the blacks the whites the Muslims the
numbers looms the hard nuts to couch the
guy I was a cool Jeff knows everyone
here giggly jokey la fée when it comes
down to being serious there now can be
as serious as anyone else if not I have
a very very scary phone book mate
yeah it's not what I can do anymore is
it it's not that so if you all can [ __ ]
your makeup so does that go all the way
back to Dennis wall or yes is what you
can call up that's what makes you
important that'll make you scary if I
can call on the Russians the Albanians
the Somalians the Chinese the yard IDO I
[ __ ] call them up I don't have to be
a good fire I'll just get you
on my telephone and say choose a weapon
let me get to something if you let me
get to my phone I don't care what
situation I mean what country I mean if
you let me get to my phone I came to you
so choice of weapon has changed to
fondness telephone 100 percent 100
percent
Wow let me get there and I'll beat you
Wow like you said you have to be born
with it which is great but you said
something earlier you said I never
touched a blow I never touched a coke
coke about a puff I've done that but
Khao County's a weirdest joke in a world
from nature actually even understand
alright because any any drug you take if
you take acid you know you better be a
message if we smoke a little weed you
know even a bit weed if you've had a bit
of an fit you know you better be a vamp
yeah if you have a bit of cocaine and
you go or I do say I'm all right nothing
wrong me I'm cool right don't want to be
cool with off quite 50 pound for
something I want to feel something but
cocaine makes you think you're alright
you feel like you can shake everything
in the room but you can't get a hard-on
it makes you choke like a complete yeah
if you ever get arrested while on
cocaine the hardest thing in the world
to do is go no coming no I'm not saying
nothing okay a little bit yeah what is
that what is that and they're walking
around saying there's nothing wrong with
me
noni taste cocaine and you ever say to
him how do you feel now go I'm at my now
they don't say no that's all right
I don't want a joke that makes me be
alright I took it for something
interesting and it's the only drug in
the world that you give it away you
don't go up to the counter of by a point
along where is that someone if you want
half of that or you go shopping and get
off your shopping and put it in another
bag of that but if you get cocaine every
time you don't have a bit let's all let
go do you want some and you give off a
bit away it's the most expensive drug
there is and that's the one that you
give it away before you even took it
you're giving over a jawline you wanna
chew ever known snips often has it he
can often and make sure you find someone
to give up a bit away to in crazy yanked
up it may come at a different
perspective but you were saying you said
you the reason you didn't do it is
because you saw someone so many of your
heroes and
so who were some of you heroes well I
still got some but I don't know I don't
want to put them in the same category of
course sure you can categorize yeah yeah
I mean of I was very close friend of the
Criterion's
ok charlie cry lived in my house I was
here I was his character reference in
his last Co case he got he got 12 years
it didn't do me no good
I buried Ronnie cry out done all the
security for his funeral that propelled
me into sort of naughty boy stardom why
do you think that is well I think is
actually exactly effortless I'll give
you a little i'll give me a little
running a bad dive code you grew yeah
sure I'm doing the doorman yeah I'm
doing this doorman thing I made one new
documentary about it's called the
Bermondsey boy and there was a bad man
preparing to go to prison and they
filming me doing the doors and they knew
urgent gaffers no seven witnesses
against me and they've got an ID
permission from Home Office to fill me
when I come out and whether prison had
worked and how many friends stayed loyal
in order and on the day before I went to
prison
somebody visited all these witnesses and
they didn't turn up so they done this
documentary of they've cooked lead a
debt collector car repossession rent a
clump you know not all there so they've
got all the bad bits and then it was
going to be easy to make it look like I
was a reformed character cuz I film some
it's bad but then I've got no QE but I
didn't know what to do with the
documentary so they just put this
documentary and tell you this is for a
year ago of this raving lunatic running
man doing all he's been with thousands
of bald-headed blokes all on his side
and what made me different is I'm
multiracial myself yeah my wife is
Jamaican you know I have my own
mixed-race children so at that time what
skinheads and black men weren't really
genuinely on the best of frame of mind
it was genuine real right money you know
my choice of lady made my army
multiracial there they didn't mind
working for me so I had six hundred big
black guys six under Muslims
eight hundred white fellows you know it
didn't matter me on my side you'd if you
could arrange take on all coming today
you understand me you will fight for
this I'm cold
but your net you know that's exactly
same as what I my army grew the
reputation grew because of the
documentary the Kray twins wanted to get
to know me so I went to go and see them
I was running over the door order the
nightclubs the Stringfellow's the
Hippodrome the Ministry of Sound all my
daughters and I wanted a little bit of
it you understand I mainly to do that
now to get more me when I was a young
impressionable man at the time couldn't
believe I'm gonna meet the craziest that
you got yeah how old were you some time
for some metal bag 26 summer on that you
were 26 24 and at that time were they in
London were they gods and I wrote
imprisoned it or there's no one no
nothing is as big as a myth mm-hmm no
one or nothing is bigger than me not the
Kray twins not Dave corny maybe no even
John got Al Capone yeah I mean nas
brings the myth you know always romantic
the real nitty-gritty bit is it the same
year crime is only glamorous in a book
or in a big screen it's not really it's
propelled me into locust and no II boy
stardom thing yeah and so now the Kray
twins died no I looked at that as the
biggest and best security job because I
had a security company
mmm-hmm I was ever gonna get this CNN
driving rounders right you know and most
criminals are supposed to conduct
himself like this they stay in the
shadows with the collar up their
pictures no common you know it's a dirty
business know that and I chose the best
150 army that I could choose to do the
security for that died mr. Glasco mr.
Newcastle mr. Liverpool mr. London mr.
Brighton mr. Leeds mr. Manchester these
were listen when I see him on meeting my
ass in the morning I wanted to invade
Iraq yeah well you know you cut out I'm
too old to say that but well it makes
you hard yeah you're looking at their
Minister I'm looking at it as the best
shelf folks you can get they're all
coming there to showed or come near to
show respect to the to the ronnie kray
yeah do you know the sort of you know
the mythical king of the underworld and
a lot of these people never really gone
with each other but for that
I know three quarters of a million paper
there and I needed a properly 150
quarters of a million three quarters of
a million people come to see when he
cried you bet there's many lady time
Winston Churchill and I to meet him with
the police chief of police and you know
this ace things in your life that you
wish you could cut your tongue hell
because you should never said it sure my
big one was I had to meet him with the
Chief of Police at the time and I was
sitting there talking away about the
security and bloodbath and I'm a little
cocky i chuja
he was sitting of Charlie cry and myself
and all these other people and he said
well the one thing we you've got mr.
coat that we've got mr. Courtney that
you haven't that your little band of men
haven't got no me nice voice not being
rude to each other said the truth is how
money trying to help you I said the
church holds 250 people there's gonna be
a million out there if you don't know
the right 250 people to live in they are
gonna get the amp and in policemen yeah
and if that policeman says you can come
to the hole in the ground cemetery and
you've got way outside if you said that
you're the wrong person they are not you
know they're not policemen fans myself
in the best being you look and do is
line the streets and leave the security
of this to me and mine because I know
what I'm talking about and who I'm
talking to
who do you let come into the funeral
parlor and kiss one each there buddy
and who do you say no to first then no
to the wrong person you're going to get
smacked in the mouth mate no service to
them and he's not liking it but he can't
argue with me and a bit nasty back as
he's Chief of Police so he has to talk
to me like that so when the one thing we
have got mr. Comey but your little band
of men haven't
he said not everyone is a criterion
friend he said there could be an
assassination attempt and the one thing
we've got to you haven't got you said
his firearms now could I cut my tongue
out what I said was please let me tell
you something the one thing you've got
no we haven't got his firearm
certificates I said we've all got
[ __ ] gun and I shouldn't have said
that I shouldn't have said that because
that made me an instant enemy of someone
from that day on he went destroyed Dave
Keuning
yeah destroy anything he does of thing
that hurt me that genuinely collapsed
one a world in their comment but for
that day is there riding in the shadows
in the thing I made it that the world is
looking at this for you no no looking
all mere mind to pick it up yeah and I
was determined to give you lot over
there in America something to look at
yes I mean if when John got you got
buried also and watch the old day yeah
you know much any horse I knew you ago
no so I made sure you had something to
look at but what I didn't realize is
that the authorities the police look
there looked at that as the very first
time of visual proof of organized crime
I said that's one criminal celebrating
the life of another criminal has
organized all these other criminals to
come down here and do Derek that's
organized crime let me ask you at that
time was it public in in London was the
public already that there was organized
crime did they all what extent it could
be if it wanted to hear when the
invention of the mob are found in a
computer like yeah but now I'll actually
know how organized crime could be until
no is visual proof of it the police mob
would a dodgy little things of
wow-wow-wow no no friends but the
general public was not aware of really
so a man could call up all the firms in
London and Ireland and Scotland and
Wales and Ireland the yard is an IRA and
triads in your cozy little one-man can
call it a pan or gamble stand on the
side of a road to protect my man
well we never seen that before and that
made them go well as well and put a
little clamp down on they repeat nerd
Dave quickly done so that's when the
populace started realizing who you are
in the front pages of paper edge
celebrity gangster heir to the throne
god I want that title where'd you go
after that title and no one runs off and
against the world into the sunset or
lives happily ever after yeah you get a
35 years retron you or a belly button in
the fridge you didn't one no I don't
want that so I quickly just as publicly
tried to go know and wrote a book stop
the ride I want to get off yeah I'm
tired you say that goes the more family
should get for being naughty the less
not you can be interesting right the
more famous you get for being naughty
listen all you get
I could even get out of my car and got
bang to the gauge you in the car beyond
because everyone would say Dave Coakley
done L see him on the telly oh no I
can't even be a debt-collection a mohawk
on running your ass and fray all around
the front room and threaten you and get
your money off you you'll go Dave
company Danny I know I must see I'm
gonna telly hmm I can't do it you have
to use different methods avoid them woke
you up at 3:00 in the morning with a
balaclava on just like we learned in bed
with your wife and an uppercut engages
not no excuse me excuse me she'll stop
church church it's about that seven
hundred thousand pound here shoots love
it's about a seven hundred thousand
memory I know you ain't going in the bed
so I kept me I'll give you a week but by
big choir huh I'll give you a week and I
will be better in awake and if I don't
get it the next time you see me I'll
give you know they're all right no no
don't worry I won't need no ornament ya
won't wake the kids but sort of funny
out what that was a new way of doing it
rather than running in a gun you owe him
run in little went up again hmm
did it hurt your business it crucified
they closed down my door company the
next day they didn't hide it they went
into the nightclubs and when you
employment they've called me security
they knew one haven't you might have a
licence for a television let alone a
nightclub
check him I mean that's the fastest way
to put your business they did it you
know and then the school was down to me
would I police pick up my children down
the road because I didn't want me
walking in the playground to clip my
kids because I was unnerving the other
parents and so how do you make money
after that huh what was your form of
making money
well my father making money was debt
collecting the car repossession the door
company no I know but after God crucify
me after that they've done everything so
I then went into the entertainment world
I started doing a bit of films my cut of
albums I wrote a few books and and it
was all working because there was
freedom of the press then right there
was freedom of the press they could
write about anyone I wanted if they 40
was interesting they could put me on as
guest speakers unless you're saying
there isn't today no no no course not no
no no there's no there's no a genuine
law in England where you cannot
glamorize crime so if I gave my book to
a book critic he would give it back to
me so I'm not allowed to do that Dave oh
I'm not allowed
say it's any good by law I'm not allowed
to say you can do in your country in
this country you're not I'm not allowed
to be on any game shows and he chapters
any radio my name is now flagged if
anyone goes to blog about me in the
press it has to go to Scotland Yard
first and if it's anything
Oh Davis I doubt that it's non listener
law I think it's two and off years old
you can check that one out it's a two
and a half year old law yes I made note
glamorized poem Virgie having that
glamorize crime verging could publish my
books but they're not allowed to put a
poster up saying David Courtney's got a
new book out because the poster is
glamorizing so how do you make money you
know I'm not making a lot of money in a
moment I'm living on what I bet yeah
I've got night club in my home I do
alright with other countries people like
this do right adora I'm more of an
invoice or an ambassador I'm no longer
an active criminal they're still on my
telephone they still him not last year
the year before last offense five
monitoring devices in my house five the
army came I've done it for me five their
remote-controlled able to brand new ones
that they drive past and got Bing and
then you can check your house there and
there's none in there and then let you
try passenger pings and your live oh I
found one more bedroom one of your
bedrooms forget all the gangsters burned
in the kitchen there me having a wank
mentor and I haven't laid off me at all
because now they have map now my biggest
threat to them is I'm making crime look
glamorous
welcome do you think you are though no
I'm not I'm not glamorizing crime i'm
glamorizing dive yeah I got him in a
cocky postman I'm in a cookie milkman
I'm just having a laugh and everything
I'm not glamorizing crime I'm telling
you now do not be a criminal hear me or
there I'm not glamorizing climb today's
a wrong time to be a criminal you are
not picking your wits against the
Sherlock I'm policemen and more you're
trying to beat technology and you can't
do that mate alright you can't do that
let's active pictures of you from the
moon knocking on the edge don't listen
to the computer game Tony Montana the
rapper they're singing about some ink
that's old like cowboys and Indians
knights in shining armor pirates they're
all romantic gangsters of the day and
gangsters are one of them
there's no longer any I'm not
glamourizing you i'm glamorizing me so
do you think that's a good thing what
that you can't be a criminal you know I
just think it's history and not you
can't be a pirate no more you can't be a
cowboy no mom no no no you can't no look
abuse no more stop with these people in
pinched web search now waiting to see
how do you get a million pound a day
you're a calculating guy you said you
know you use knife 20 years you use gun
this many years you use you know brass
you know that's gonna give you 18 months
right you sure you're pretty good
cocaine you know you do cocaine you have
to share with somebody who smoke weed
you don't you know acid all of a sudden
you're very calculating it's very
obvious you're very calculating
so today do you think the internet and
what's happened do you think that is
making the world safer because I'm
person tell me so go go tech so you
you're going to route of the government
has more control over the people then
there's every control ever to figure out
it and if they wanted to stop drugs that
could stop in drugs they didn't want to
name criminals and they could stop the
criminals coming out there they need
criminals the biggest employer in
America is the legal system the biggest
employer for the out of America is the
prison officers the policeman the
traffic wardens the slits is the judges
the house tools the information officers
rape everyone stired not parking on a
double yellow line do you think that
England they're gonna sack 1 million
traffic wardens do you mean if they
generally everyone stop Devon's crime
they've got a sec 50 million placement
80,000 prison officers so you know they
don't want their I have to publicly be
same by that little box in the corner to
be doing the right thing you had a
computer or whatever you understand my
meaning of course yeah they can convince
England from the television to go over
to another country and blow it up for
weapons of mass destruction and then go
auxillary we were wrong cough if they
can do that I can convince you of
anything
I let him say things about me on a tell
you know I actually went to cope with a
bent policeman and I went arm taping him
and he was going no he's paying me i
bugged him so i got not guilty and the
couple in the prison excuse me can I
just hold myself and saying that I went
I'm gonna coat the copper got five years
and I've got not guilty
the old base other right right but they
were actually rather than me come out
and write another book and everyone
loves Dave cool they actually started
moving to I was an informant
I was hmm really what if I answered it
with one word yeah bird I might be an
informant but who can't go well Corey's
an informant hoodie grass up Morden I
just heard he was tipping a word or
Wendy yeah um they said about me had it
been believed I shot the police
create your overall do they allow the
rumor to come out of Dave Courtney pays
the place they've called he's got the
police in his area
yeah he's the cop type couldn't win a
coke dress as a clown the couple went to
prison and Dave got not guilty do you
think they're gonna allow that to happen
if they've got control of the press or
do you think they won't I'm marching you
know that makes sense are you familiar
with the Donnie Brasco story Joe Pistone
favorite area the FBI goes to lefty and
they say he is in Turkey as an informant
and left he doesn't believe it but he
ends up being an informant and in this
case you're saying you're not but badly
what was your friction with is it
Frankie Fraser what was the friction
friction the truth by over here Frankie
Freddie's wife ran off with my doorman
and he hated my guts for ever ever since
I couldn't prove to him I didn't know
about it I didn't know about it I know
called a bear but that's what happened
and when they all that come up in the
copper went all now I'm paying Dave
Frankie went you're believing those
gross so important in Dalton on it even
though the rest of the whole of the
underworld like the Ronnie and Reggie
Christ and I was all right Ronnie big
said I'm all right Charlie Bronson said
I'm all right Richardson Frankie pretty
much the only one that didn't sell so it
was him because his wife had run off for
Meyer
yeah and I didn't like him for that yeah
I went round his house and I went down
battery but when I went man there is 78
he's seven stone I couldn't even hit him
a break and I loved what was that
conversation like when you guys said who
were no conversation issues here we only
do he had no teeth in a string vest I
mean I can't even eat you you're break
you can silly little man now look at you
off you know I didn't want someone to
don't shoot me just can y'all believe
the police and then it went to call I
was found not guilty so there shouldn't
be no room I was
okay the policemen went to prison I had
the tape on and bugged the copper walk
became more proof do you want
I would've cooked whis is a clown and
bad him what do you want me to do
understand mommy but he's decided to go
now I still believe the copper so it
made it real freedom but not L freely
enough of me do anything he's eight
years old and had he actually because he
was a really big myth he done 47 years
in prison and I don't know it ones go he
got caught with everything you ever done
the silly bastard everything he ever
done he got caught and now he's done 47
years in prison
aren't supposed to look up to him
because he's done 47 years in prison but
it's an [ __ ] he's a complete nob and
that little myth about you got to prison
and learn a lot of new crimes that's not
true
you're only gonna meet people that got
Kiko oh you're gonna learn in Aries how
not to do it
nobody knows gonna be no criminal genius
because you're all in prison
oh you're gonna learn all day long is
there gonna tell you this is our cocoa
as L go co-anchor gloves fingerprints
GPS they know tell you and they got cold
so if you didn't come out of prison and
you want to carry on being a criminal if
you can remember all the ways that they
told you they get cool then you're a
bear criminal because you've remembered
all the ways I've got coke but no one in
there is gonna chase you out do it
properly because you know cool does that
not make serious I understand what
you're saying I mean I understand the
point you're making and he said he had
40 hits right in his career he had some
number like that is would you read about
about him doctor
yeah that mean that's what it because I
know old of the paper that grew up in
his era yeah to put in the papers che
fairs over far it's all not real he
never ever as part of the myth he'll
never happen so let me ask you he came
during the era of the crows yeah the
Kray twins so who were the Kray twins in
London how were they ace London okay it
was a lot easier to be an art not then
because they won't look right men around
we just come out of a war and all of our
men have been killed so there weren't a
lot of men men around Johnny our man is
that what you're saying it was very poor
these two little brothers was in East
London it was quite easy to run bare
norine in in them days because there's
only 12,000 people living in East London
now there is 750,000 people living in
London and none of them are from can't
even say the name cratering in them days
they spoke and understood English all
right when the crater engineer they
spoke and understood England English
everyone was skin.you there was no
muggings and burglaries and you could
leave your front door key on a piece of
string because who's gonna break in your
ass what the [ __ ] if you got in your
house there was nothing in there to Nick
right it was 1950 there's no-one had
nothing
you're breaking someone's ass and leave
him a fire furnace you need feel
terrible no one had nothing so they run
East London there was a little firm
called dams I remember turning a minute
run no Flandern and the Richardson's run
South London the Nessie's run North
London yeah Ritchie says with the
cleverest by far they both invested in
diamond mines and all that blah blah
blah nobody answered when interpreter
but the Criterion's went for the glamour
they went for the headlines newspaper
rings they even borrowed other people's
nightclubs to pretend at their own you
know when they died the mums old still
living in the same council s they were
boning yeah one was gay and dip mind
saying he was gay and if anyone said he
was gay he would walk into a pub in
front of everyone a shoo-in for it and
yep one was gay but didn't I tell
everyone so he got married didn't sleep
his wife a year and she killed herself
that's the truth of it if I told you
anything that weren't right I'd get shot
I'm not talking about football or acting
or singing I'm talking about a naughty
boys world and if I'm wrong about
anything I can't tell you this can I I
would job be too silly Church I'm
telling you what's in you is fact and
Frankie Fraser was nobody ever [ __ ]
he lived in an old Caravan on the
Richardson's bloody one of their
Breakers yards and they came back with
someone one day with a sack over him
that they'd give him a clump I tied him
to a chair got Frankie Fraser to wear
their bait was whacking him he was
cuckoo Moon River liar so I got Frankie
Fraser to take them to fing off all
right so the bloke saw Frankie when when
they'd let him go any winter coat what
he said was I was getting beat up inside
the sack
the pain was they excruciating they it
felt like Frankie Fraser was pulling my
teeth out with pliers all right
full stop when they reported the story
in the morning to the public and the
jury before the case ended then you've
got carte blanche as a journalist [ __ ]
you can start that conversation wherever
you want and as they as they went he
said and Frankie Fraser was pulling my
teeth out were pliers
stop now it suited the Richardson's to
let the rest of the world think that
they had a torturer and he suited
Frankie Fraser for the rest of the world
to think he was connected to the
Richardson's as he's only a [ __ ]
little skinny tense town when where and
it suited him to let him think he was
criminal collected and it suited them to
think that they had a soldier er I
didn't have to actually hang around with
him because he was in prison for 47 10
years so it just suited everyone and
then when he left he come out he's so
deluded that on the cover of his book
he's 78 instead of sitting there with
the globe in a library and talking about
crime right there he actually went ha ha
ha thinking he was still as scary folks
you know I completed a table yeah sorry
you can see I read that line a guy yeah
but I'm not saying anything no he's a
liar and if because I've been saying it
for about him for 20 years while he was
alive had anything that anyone believed
about him was true I won't be allowed to
say there's something would have
happened to me had it been true what he
was saying about you what what myth
about the Kray twins Wooster would they
feared would they know definitely they
weren't there were no a bit of work but
there wasn't as well organised or its
well feared as was still possible they
were in East London
I knowed yeah yeah that postcode Yun's
down I mean Ian we've got the same
little postcode words now but yeah
you've seen seven hundred thousand now
back then it was 12,000 that's a big
yeah so else would be some of your
heroes what would you like for us like a
Guardian some of those they have a
little bit of Tennyson am Jimmy right
today all grew slipping back we've gone
back now and we're started right after
I'll write the books doctor right away
together and it all come out about me
wearing the
me wearing the pink joke oh yeah I don't
get our guests an invite to go to Sicily
to the private audience with 425
businessmen in their villa with five
interpose for five grand
so meaning go to Sicily yeah and we get
there and it's the king you know we only
see them on telly and I'm happy with
what comes from Jim Peckham I you know I
mean yeah we think my bad but we only
say down on the telly yeah but these are
the bad ones and it was bonus kony
before he was punished and all these
other people well I didn't know they
were it was just a mental for me and he
was talking in broken English which
makes it all sound gangster eat Russians
that me know you don't talk to me about
gangster boy and a 1 million you see
sandy lair I don't want many bank
robbers I know 1 million murderers I
don't know any man it's gonna put
dressed like that punched a copper in
the face before he was tenant I said you
tell me about that day he said because
there is an unwritten rule book about
going to cook and that goes round in the
whole world apart from the Cosa Nostra
and I tell you why when he says first
rule they're not bring all your friends
with you
it says we're not sir yes sir no sir
pleasure thank you
and a letter from someone that's known
you 20 years saying you're a nice guy
Denham rules I've kind of cool in
whatever country we go to the only
people that don't have to abide by them
is us because they the judge knows it's
John Gotti it's not working coming being
all [ __ ] nice like that and yeah
because he knows exactly what he is and
who is there so they come into court
gangster huh they come into court like
lumps in their pocket and he went the
only person I've ever seen do that is
you amazed you mean so you tell me tell
me what made you go cool like that with
all your friends walking bass the cop
addresses it gonna tell me that day I'll
give you your money
oh yeah so I've told him that day but
over there anyway that's it done alright
because when I come home he's now ending
up being the prime minister blow and end
the Italian bookshelf for true crime
it's the smallest bookshelf in the world
in every in any other country
interesting right because I got the
Mafia there they're not interested in
crates when the Great Train Robbery yogi
thing here they've got the map here in
the corner of Rome bookshop you said I
haven't got all the other different
nationality ones that we have well I
need up getting my book in there which
I've always been really great only
because a Scania dengan on
these guys publishers you've made a bit
yeah I've got in Italian I'm gonna tell
him so then the Gambino's what happened
after that they're all doing a little
bit of talking then jay-z put mark
picture on a cover of his album on
blueprint I spoke to the Oxford Union
and they bought a book about it and he
thought that was really funny a
convicted felon teaching future
Parliament actor behavior they've
currently talking to the Oxford Union on
how to behave that's funny
yeah educate me funny so he put my photo
of addiction in his head on it and
called it blueprint I'm sitting there
talking to her to future Parliament
least what he said on it
so that's happened so what that's being
talked about there's a book out about it
and the Gambino's their family I don't
know who they will how I out there were
but they when they come over they have a
six-week vacation in trouble Europe
didn't they say they're all can't man
Europe and they've gone it they've got
in touch with Freddie Foreman Aires a
superior in the crime world to me yeah
and said we want to go to the Ministry
of Sound well that was one my doorman so
he goes David listen uncle some got some
young American kids every write down
again a minister loose and he said just
so you know with all that buttocks why
would you look after them for me you
know of course it will Fred no problem
general come around my house said these
young 15 kids come around my asses to
look like lumps but they won't they
won't their dad and their child to be
their friend Jerry you know I've had a
wicked some of my ass of ever laughing
choking a little path when it couldn't
show him well appointed minister sound
about a team wiki night didn't want to
go back to the hotel stayed the night in
my house I've got big old out I had a
[ __ ] great them know by the time they
go back to whatever mom and dad they got
there they're going they take they take
they don't they yeah they take things
doing all right out there in America at
anyway we've already have a little
things of you know Jay Z and rancid I
don't if you've earned the band rancid
hmm one of their one of their tracks on
their album so I've got the the
naughtiest white guys singing about Dave
Courtney in America I've got the
naughtiest black guy singing about dope
Gambino's kids all going he's been
lovely I've got a in the Mafia bloke who
ended up being the Prime Minister of
Italy again good book good book right so
now we're all going over to America I
never done I've listened do some what
you gonna be there for I for the Virgin
for the book thing and I ended up not
selling it in America because I have
competing we smoke a cigar on a cover
because the cigar was undercover and
they were not comfortable with that
anyway by the time it gets over there
there can't be no people they'd heard I
was coming he's my pal but he's a coward
he's brave enough of things but it is
coward I baby I'll leave it with me
beautiful but the fighting thing and a
gangster thing really honest I'm saying
right and so we get to the airport and
these two blacks come over to us and I'm
gonna fulfill this one there he goes mr.
Kearney I'm gonna have to separate you
from your company at the moment but this
is very important people don't need to
say hello to you it won't take a long
time so I'm ready to start splitting so
they could jump me away help me help me
so can get killed just I mean he's going
that's all I might get off we go check
him alone up Suites in like you know
Eterna me
but it's just Gambino alone and they're
taking me around to me all these people
I've never met before
old men smelling a little bit like
tomorrow's all them weren't looking at
how black my pictures I didn't know
anyone but looked after the kids have
blood all things like that you know
cranky chops you better yet so no coming
out here Joe there go in there to
jay-z's club so we got the jg scrub we
don't know if so the tribals gotta come
in the car guys I take it in don't worry
I think yeah so he takes us there to
jay-z's club I'm going to be
knowledgeable of now I'm buzzing on you
right I'm not saying I'm learning I'm
not I'm not a mean I'm not a base you're
not baseball
no no scary phonebook customer game yeah
no anime no right
so heating cuz I take you so he gets us
to this club there's a big letter Q got
beside and the big gig on that side and
these doorman English people don't come
that big
I don't know way you Americans get black
men that be a ton of I must really their
mom coming out they must really a term
um because I saw that for real you know
I've got Imaginext missus in New York in
the UK yeah it's crazy anyway so then he
pulls up because wait a minute and he
just runs up the stairs talks to the
abdominal there girl and I would not
come out so when we come up and just let
me let me straight in and I was gonna
die on a me come up so we're gonna put
me carry said I'll just give me that man
and as I'm walking up to to give him my
back turned you're talking these guys I
don't know would have feeling man
I'd done order because when if he's got
the can't be no stuff anymore periods of
camp I'm gonna be a nice to the guy from
something that a tricks not trick you
know I may not all that happened you
know I couldn't have planned it I
couldn't planned all of that kind of
Sicily during them get him a book out
over there jay-z put Monica everything
Gambino's Tenakee I couldn't handle you
know I mean you couldn't everybody ended
up like that that's amazing that's
amazing we need you know you read about
the Kray twins it goes back to how
Sinatra used to come here and he's right
to hire their security that's right Judy
Garland used to come and do things with
them I mean they were published aid they
were prostitutes with publish a their me
for they were properly possible yeah
prostitutes for publicists right yeah
like they they coated the press
massively young Shama main in and that's
what actually eventually got them coke
once I mean is what they were run away
and believed it all actually run away
and believed their own hope yeah in
reality when they died that between them
all they never had fifty thousand pounds
there wasn't never regret and and they
didn't own a house there
mom dinner designer and how does that
happen do I mean huh what I just didn't
want money that wanted Fame more than
they did one yeah yeah yes right
huh and the Richardson's wanted the
money they had the money and the power
that's right yeah huh and what the
program what the place and the press
done is they made them to fight each
other you know what I made eight they
caused the conflict so that much due to
a fight and it's easier for the police
to come home I was in here at mania West
Side Eastern or I can they can cause
conflict and actually gets him get some
cold you know and then Richardson's
didn't want conflict but they made all
that happen oh I actually instigated the
very first time the richest has met
Christ after 30 years I took Charlie
Richardson who got our prisons to come
visit Reggie Kray who was imprisoned it
both went inside for years and Frankie
Fraser or you said yeah how was the
meeting
yeah Mary's like well you could yeah I
like talking but that was just you den
it was like electric and I just went
into this prison and now it's a go I
just push the stick tables up together
no one said nothing and they all set
around it those open each other's hands
like wow really yeah yeah really
Nene look a little of you saw something
if you'd respect the unity so Amy agent
last time they saw each other them yeah
beautiful
when when did it kind of uh not
necessarily disappear when did it kind
of all settle down a bit here Yoshio
down a bit yeah
a series I went a prison they all got 30
years y'all got 30 of us there you got
in there how firm got say 10 20 or not
you what is not a good advert for
British crime he's on the dyno sentence
their solicitor who's not an assassin
and my barrister said to them the
evidence against you is so strong they
is impossible to get knock your way
right so the deal what got for you is if
you want to go Gilley
I can let the rest of your whole firm
out if you go knock your way you are all
gonna get 20 years and you
I'm gonna get five years but if you want
to go guilty now your whole firm can
walk and you have to get found guilty
there was too much against you you
walked into the pub and shot him you
ain't gonna get away with that yeah
everyone saying they said you know and
they went now that we won our Fermi with
us we won't have farm in prison with us
and chose to bring them in prison with
them when I could have let them go that
makes me wanna [ __ ] me and be
embarrassed to be an English criminal
there's not leader material is it they
could have said QE and let the whole
firm go home but I went no Kiwi and took
the whole firm to prison with him what
why do they do that he's got a power in
well because they were too frightened to
go prison on their own outside of prison
yeah they had an army random inside
prison know going to be segregated on
their own so they took their army and
with them and then after being
imprisoned for just 24 15 months
Reggie wrote a book meeting it all
anyway Turner this one has become
Christian not real but he just powered
of course there's nothing else to do
he became openly gay in prison and all
that in the Christian bit was to
hopefully give him a little bit of
leeway that they might let him out but
the only thing he had left to do to say
I'm a nice bloke now you and Salman was
turned Christian but he's how firm which
I know well which were all good friends
of mine were gobsmacked
I've just got 20 years he got 10 years
all right they know they'd been offered
the deal to go go guilty and win at your
firm off none of the firm come when he
say to him go guilt we go get what we go
guilty because every man's got the right
to try and win a court case mm-hmm but I
was thinking you know so they lived with
it even though he didn't go get where
they all went a prison and then I think
it was 24 or 36 months after that he
wrote a book of meeting anyway so they
went what did you what did he drop
everyone names in the book why didn't
you have me yeah that you did it then
and then none of us would about to go to
prison
did their people two people turn against
them or no
they now locked up and I was turned into
mythical characters all of a sudden the
West and the East End start again filled
up with Indians Pakistanis Polish
Russians Jamaicans Irish and they lost
their English culture and they got all
wrapped up in the rabbit so we think it
was all because the Kray twins went away
let me ask you this let me ask you know
how a military has a code you know the
Italian mafia has a code the La Cosa
Nostra has a code what was the code that
what's there a code you guys lived by
and guess what was of code I'm gonna
tell you generation to generation I tell
you watch no no England just come have a
war and a spy or a grass was the worst
thing in the world one spies more
dangerous than a thousand men walls have
ears and all of that so if you're the
policeman at that time and you caught a
criminal yeah and you become a snitch
you would get captured in ribbons you'd
get killed too many snakes if you were
to create a placement of time your job
was hard because no one classed anybody
up ending was known as the Bulldog
Nation then you could pull their
fingernails out and we wouldn't tell
anyone
so wouldn't tell the secrets that was
what ingdom was about all right and then
they realized that the Warren at the
more years had made a nation of none
informants so they spent the next 60 and
50 years convincing you that informing
was good on every single in television
station now on every single channel on
prime-time television if you want said
this to me 25 years ago I called you a
liar there was your program going and if
you see this guy just ring us up and we
give you some money and if there's
another tool we got one phone call
already come on and if you see this
phone if you see these yeah and then
there's a thing in every newspaper if we
know someone that's working while
climbing social if you know anyone
selling drugs if you know anyone selling
arms if you know anyone that's
drink-driving
not they've made grassing acceptable
good and now if you get caught for being
an informant you don't get beat up in
prison you're going to your former swing
where the other twenty thousand of you
are so it ain't such a bad thing no more
so they have Nerdrum down to England
that informing is good and then some
bright spark is now gone
if your mom and dad smack your bomb they
banned the kind I banned the kind which
meant if you're a boy
game 6 wax of course the arts would have
been wood at the end as I stopped you
being noe you get a detention or child
offers I mean yeah getting someone's
smack you across to bumming a bit would
at the end of the day put manners on you
yeah mm-hmm right they banned that and
now someone's just banned it that you
cannot smack your own kids
if you smack your mum if your mum Smet
you you can tell us and we will put in
prison they teach the children five five
nine three three two one four they teach
them the telephone number to ring if
your own mum and dad discipline you then
18 Hitler Youth lost your mum and dad up
if they smack you so you got no
discipline at school and you've now got
no discipline home your own mum can't
give you a smack on a bum all right so
what charge does the kid got when he
gets to sixteen seven and leaves home to
go in a big walk really don't know
discipline and I said what we're going
to do about you for today you've lost
that war is done yeah because of that
and they now teach children to go and
grass on your mum and dad if you get
smacked mum well somewhere along the
line now it's going to come back and
bite you teaching your country to be
informants and putting it on telly and
having all of that and teaching your
kids to cross at your mum and dad or
somewhere down the line there's will
come back and bite you because that
don't make a proper men yes we've done
well today Jimmy cold what's the code
the code is old army things like the
whole country was army orientated don't
tell tales not short haircuts love your
mum shiny shoes night sir
it was army the whole country was army
fired the how youth of the whole when
Syria was was that was the gangsters
code the same you look after your mom
you nice and tidy nice and smart you do
not charge you never leave one man
behind you all the army things come
straight out into road that's the code
and what I've done there in today's
world is they broke all the up and made
it not right when it is right they still
teach you that in the army but when it
when the war finished which alright the
fifties nobody throwing one away that
that discipline was still on now
everyone left the army and we're still
doing bank robberies people are 10 or 15
people winning there were lot army
maneuvers now you only rob a bank with
one or two but they were you know it was
all army fighting the code was you do
not tell towers like the army yeah you
do not run away and leave a man down
right nice shiny shoes shoe haircuts
and love your mum hmm and that was the
code on the road there one away and
they've now broke that down so that
ain't near and I don't if I introduced
you to 20 different criminals 25 years
ago you'll see an armed robber a cat
burglar a kidnapper of in a murderer now
you're just doing narcotics and with the
vast amount of money involved in
narcotics everything and everyone is
probable law policeman gangsters you
know means you don't get someone killed
once was 20 grand it was a love the
money neighing jeongae done for go go
don't have to have enemies you don't get
caught for it just are some little
Russian bloke who lives in Norwich to
come down and do it
mmm-hmm done goes back up there I'm
afraid the only way I be a successful
drug dealer Nerys to be on that side
I'll get chastised for saying that but
the the informant Network they have was
so good
no one could be a drug dealer the police
not know I can be stupid enough to freak
me you are a drug dealer and that being
a drug know what's the pranic on of that
the prone economies you can sell more if
more people know you're doing it but the
police will know so the police will just
find a way to actually get you working
for him no one's ever going to go I'm
your Foreman if I actually catch you and
go right but you found out you're a
smoked and that will these photographs
I've now got 20 years for you 20 years
for you some 20 years we adore in 2003
work or do not want to work for me
because you're getting that what you
want don't quick is that literally it
right necessary work how long has it
been like this a long time and that's
how it works
anyone there doing it okay each one so
let me let me ask you this final
thoughts here okay you you you've seen a
lot you've done a lot I mean obviously
we didn't get into a lot of the things
you've done yourself because you have a
rap sheet yourself on the things you
you're at a different phase of your life
right now right yeah you've seen a lot I
mean you know when someone comes in
you're extremely ambitious I'm gonna
make my point I'm a leader on the
delegator I'm gonna be able to figure
out exactly what I do in a boom a little
bit more I got to make money I've
realized how important the money part is
the famous year kind of got me away from
being able to make the money I used to
make before all this other stuff and now
this is a different phase right life is
about a lot of different phases what are
you looking back now saying you know
Dave you like you said you bit your
tongue you shouldn't have told the cop
that we all have guns except you have a
certificate we don't what do you have
any other thing where somebody a young
man is watching that somebody's watching
the same what can I be sorry for them
because I and and the efforts to
everyone when they get older and
whatever field you're in crime as well
you you long to do that
yeah put your head on someone and teach
them and let you know what I know
without having to go through all the
hardships but in the crime world now
what I know and what I'm used to is no
good to you anymore trusting someone
being good character shaking your hand
and all that means nothing now the more
nasty and come how in spiteful and
murderous you are the more respect you
get the more murdering deceitful you are
they're the ones it's making it so well
I've gotten off on that crime world is
very old-fashioned and I would come very
second very quick I've got nothing to
offer them I'll just forget them I'm
gonna cry
and that's God's honest truth please and
there's nothing more rewarding than
being able to go let me help you
meaning you get out or that's that's
more sane yeah yeah just looking at
Scarface on the video yeah there is no
more there is no more him
there's no mourning and the only ones
that they let him be them gangsters now
sending the drugs I working for the
police who the police now they're drug
dealers I don't think there's any drug
dealer that the police don't know your
drug dealer so the reason they're
letting you be one is because you're
working for him
if I wanted to stop you that would stop
you so listen I mean we can sit in you
can go with stories it's endless stories
I mean it's like non-stop with you and
stories but you
I appreciate you coming out and being
willing to share and more than anything
else sometimes it's great to hear
somebody who's gone through the life
you've seen it you've hung out with all
the people that people read about and
you're coming back and saying you know I
don't know if I recommend this lifestyle
I don't know if I recommend you wanting
to go this route maybe take a different
route for your life to the young people
that I watch understand might be I'm
trying definitely taking that one maybe
if you'd watch me at 30 years ago
come on Shady so right but right now is
the wrong time to be a criminal man so
wrong time to be a criminal wrong time
powerful to know that this is the wrong
time to be a criminal because it just
means it's safer for all that is so to
say Courtney is in the building
believe it seems that my technique
there's a good one with it yeah that was
a good so having said that we're gonna
end on this if you have any thoughts any
questions that you took away from
today's interview SEM you tweet at
Patrick David again thanks for coming
out to value time appreciate your time
well thank you